SHOVE IT OUT AND IN THE
KORPISALO GETS IT CIRELLI THERE
STAMKOS.
THIS IS ONE O O CLUB ZACH JAKE.
A KEY ISN PLAYED
HOCKEY IN THE79%. IS ONE OF THE
UNDERROREY
PERRY.
CARLSSON GETS SOME HE
LOW TO HEIGHT.
PALAT
CIRELLI.
PUCK PICKED UP.
RADDYSH DROPS IT BACK.
RADDYSH WILL TAKE IT THERE FROMG
IN MONTREAL THE LAST YEAR.
IN THE STANLEY CUP FINALS THE
LAST COUPLEUP.
A LOT OF BACK AND FORTH.
PENALTY KILLERS S
FOLLOWED JAKE THERE ON THAT
SEQUENCE.DOMI.
A GOOD JOB HERE COMMUNICATING.
BOQVIST OPENS UP FROM
KURALY. THE BLUE
LINE.
GAVRIKOV TRIED TO MAKE THE PASS
AND IT
MCDONAGH.
TEAMS KORPISALO.
TO CERNAK.
KNOCKED BY JENNER WHO DROPS IN
FR DELAYED PENALTY
>> Jeff: THEY HAD THE POWER PLAY
ENTRY STANDING
FACEOFF.
14 IN WHITE GETS THE GOAL.
COREY PERRY
HE WILL PICK IT UP IN THE  GOAL.
HERE WE ARE WITH TA BY VASILEVS.
MAROON.
AHEAD.
COREY PERRY NOW. SEE
THE PUSH OFF THE OPENING DRAW.
JAKE
KILLORN HAS HAD A
>> Jody: A HIGH STICK.
NO ARM WENT UP FROM ANYBOQVIST..
THE OILERS GAVE THEM SOME LIFE.
>> Jeff: HEDMAN 3 POWER PLAY
JACKETS HAVE GIVEN UP 7
KATCHOUK.
AWAY FROM HARRINGTON.